and welcome to hannity on this busy
breaking news friday night joe biden
wrapping up yet another disastrous week
of his imploding presidency filled with
more bizarre blunders more failed policy
and yes more really horrific economic
data we're going to break it all down
tonight now earlier today joey was seen
fist bumping with the saudi crown prince
you know the same prince that he called
the murder of jamal khashoggi
the same nation that he called the
pariah nation biden claimed in his
remarks tonight that he did bring up the
issue of khashoggi i'm sure he was
really firm
he also confirmed that yes he did beg
for more oil but details were few and
far between take a look
we had a good discussion on ensuring
global energy security and adequate oil
supplies to support global economic
growth and that will begin shortly
and and i'm doing all i can to increase
the supply for the united states of
america which i expect to happen
the saudis share that urgency and based
on our discussions today i expect we'll
see
further steps in the coming weeks coming
under a lot of fire for your fist bump
with the crown prince
i just want to give you a chance to
respond to that but also how can you be
sure that another incident another
murder like jamal khashoggi won't happen
again well god love you what a silly
question how could i possibly be sure of
any of that
i just made it clear if anything occurs
like that again they'll get that
response and much more
oh silly question you know what the sad
thing is we don't need saudi arabian oil
we've got plenty here gas oil coal we
don't need it but yet again today biden
showing nothing but weakness on the
world stage and suffered yes another
batch of blunders i'm sure this shocks
you take a look
i was making a speech
and
i had a terrible headache
excuse me a terrible headache
and uh
sorry
thank you
didn't the media mob attack marco rubio
for taking a sip of water well there's
one one saving grace he didn't shake air
again like he did the day before it only
got worse from there because biden also
made a bizarre comparison while speaking
in jerusalem by linking the plight of
irish catholics under british rule to
the
israeli-palestinian conflict
what take a
now the look
expression
hope springs eternal
i uh
my background
in the background of my family is irish
american
and uh
we
have a uh
a long history
of uh
not fundamentally unlike the palestinian
people
with uh great britain and their attitude
toward irish catholics
over the years for 400 years
and get this biden's trip is going so
poorly that it's even drawing the ire of
the congenital compromised corrupt liar
that is adam schiff he tweeted about
biden's saudi arabia visit said quote if
we ever needed a visual reminder of the
continuing grip oil rich autocrats have
on u.s foreign policy in the middle east
oh we got it today
one fist pump is worth a thousand words
if ever there was a sign a more obvious
sign that democrats were ready to move
on from biden this is it it couldn't be
more clear maybe the congenital liar
should join us and support american
energy independence you know the trump
policies
now it caps off yet another rough week
for team biden as the president's
blunders abroad that was just the latest
in a long string of struggles revealing
once again biden is weak he is frail he
is decrepit he is not up to the job this
country should be seriously considering
the 25th amendment take a look
every time i hear hail of the chief
wonder where the hell is
he took me a long while you think i'm
joking i'm not
turning around where where's where's the
president mr president what's your
message to democrats who don't want you
to run again
they want me to run two thirds say they
don't
read the polls jack
you guys are all the same
[Music]
and continue which we must do every
every day continue to bear witness to
keep alive the truth and honor of the
holocaust horror of the holocaust
thank you president herzog and president
biden
yeah look at the polls jack
oh nobody's there just another reason
why more and more democrats they are
looking for someone other than biden
with over 60 percent not wanting biden
to run in 2024 this week biden inflation
hit yet the highest number ever another
40 plus year high at 9.1 percent and
even worse a new record near new record
wholesale inflation that spike to a
whopping 11.3 percent when it gets to
retail on that level you'll pay for all
of it and like i've been saying
everything you buy at every store you go
to is costing you more it's why food
bank lines are now longer than ever with
americans now overwhelmed by surging
prices at the grocery store look at
these findings from the associated press
hardly part of the vast right-wing
conspiracy for example phoenix they have
a food bank their main distribution
center they gave out food packages to
over four thousand two hundred families
during the third week in june that is a
seventy eight percent increase from the
same week last year alameda california
that county there is also seeing a big
increase as is houston los angeles and
so many others and biden's and his far
left enablers they've been lying and
lying and lying about inflation one time
after another take a look
i really doubt that we're going to see
an inflationary cycle most economic
analysts believe that it will have a
temporary transitory impact faster than
expected increase in some of those
prices is actually a good sign the
overwhelming consensus is going to pop
up a little bit and then go back down
it's highly unlikely that it's going to
be long-term inflation that's going to
get out of hand i don't know anybody
who's worried about inflation over the
last couple of months
we actually saw it trended downward make
no mistake inflation is largely the
fault of putin i'm going to do
everything i can to minimize putin's
price hike here at home if you want to
get rid of inflation the only way to do
it is to um
undo a lot of the trump tax cuts
now these surging costs they all stem
from joe biden's failed economic and
energy policies of course artificially
reducing the supply of the lifeblood of
the world's economy that's energy while
attacking u.s oil and gas and the
industry all together and letting the
far left climate religious cult agenda
run the country only under far left
logic is it okay to beg foreign
governments for more oil while not
wanting to drill domestically right here
at home it's not just a joe biden
problem either with the exception of
maybe joe manchin this is the new green
deal socialist democratic party and any
other democrat if they were in power
they would be making the same dumb
idiotic decisions how is it okay to get
oil from russia iran uh opec saudi
arabia and venezuela but we don't
produce it domestically tell me the
logic behind that now the people around
him are no better and frankly they're
the worst kind of enablers vice
president harris she is totally
unprepared to be president as we've now
learned yet again today another staffer
is leaving as she makes one word salad
after another she's almost as bad as
biden but for a little bit different
reasons take a look
together we are expanding access to
transportation
seems like maybe it's a small issue it's
a big issue you need to get to go and
need to be able to get where you need to
go to do the work and get home
even the first lady jill biden while
she's not doing her husband any favors
because as democrats continue to lose
more and more support among hispanic
voters well jill biden decided it was a
good idea to compare hispanic americans
to tacos take a look
raul helped build this organization
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else